spätestens seit der industrialisierung
optimieren wir uns menschen durch
technik und wissenschaft immer wieder
geht es ja hier bei uns um cyborgs also
mischwesen aus mensch und maschine und
ich wette es dauert nicht mehr lange bis
wir alle einen röntgenblick haben oder
eine ähnliche bahnbrechende optimierung
solch eine künstliche erweiterung des
menschen wird auch human enhancement
genannt ihr habt euch dieses thema bei
whatsapp gewünscht und bekommt jetzt
alle wichtigen facts dazu was ist
bereits heute möglich und was ist für
die nahe zukunft geplant und werden wir
menschen bald unsterblich jetzt in
klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen das thema human enhancement
also die künstliche verbesserung des
menschen lässt sich in drei bereiche
aufteilen schon längst erweitern wir den
menschlichen körper mechanisch also
beispielsweise durch prothesen oder
herzschrittmacher zur
leistungssteigerung nutzen wir
medizinische hilfsmittel und
gentechnische verfahren setzen wir
beispielsweise in der gentherapie und
präimplantationsdiagnostik ein schon
seit jahren wird das thema doping im
leistungssport diskutiert und nicht
zuletzt längst haben sportler bei den
paralympics künstliche körperteile
oft sind sie mit solchen prothesen
schneller als ihre konkurrentinnen und
die frage steht im raum ist das
sportlich fair
vielleicht erinnert ihr euch an oscar
pistorius der 2008 vom internationalen
sportgerichtshof das recht bekam bei den
regulären olympischen spielen
mitzulaufen mit prothesen aber auch in
unseren körpern gibt es implantate
mittlerweile auch elektronisch die daten
an den behandelnden arzt oder die ärztin
senden vor allem bei herz und hirn
schrittmachern ist das gängige praxis
und auch hier gibt es sowohl vor als
auch nachteile der datenschutz der hier
bedroht sein könnte steht einem notfall
gegenüber bei dem ein automatischer
notruf der implantate leben retten kann
oder hier auch bei der apple wort stehe
auch sehr eng mit dem körper verbunden
ist noch wird hier der notruf von hand
ausgelöst aber durch human enhancement
werden wir menschen längst nicht nur
gesünder und schneller sondern auch
stressresistenter stichwort ritalin oder
modafinil
medikamente deren einsatz medizinisch
nicht notwendig ist uns aber im
arbeitsalltag leistungsfähiger machen
soll
auch das menschliche erbgut können wir
optimieren wir berichten ja immer öfter
mal darüber die
präimplantationsdiagnostik also die
diagnostik bevor ein befruchtetes
menschliches auge implantiert wird dies
immer wieder auch thema in
bundestagsdebatten die große frage hier
in wie weit ist die anwendung
therapeutisch wann wird diese
technologie wohl genutzt um ein wunsch
baby zu produzieren was genau die
genetischen anlagen hat die sich die
eltern vorstellen
bei den techniken aus dem bereich human
enhancement steht die therapie im
hintergrund es geht wie gesagt um eine
verbesserung oder optimierung der
menschen das ist der fall wenn durch die
technik dinge möglich werden die die
fähigkeiten der menschen allein
übersteigt deutlich wird das am beispiel
des hörgeräts bei einem patienten einer
patientin die wegen eines unfalls oder
einer krankheit durch ein solches gerät
wieder normal hören kann handelt sich
ganz eindeutig um eine therapie wenn das
gehör gerät aber es möglich macht
frequenzen zu hören die wir menschen
normalerweise nicht hören dann ist das
ein klarer fall von human enhancement
aber sind wir deswegen deswegen auch
gleich dann cyborgs es gibt experten die
überzeugt davon sind dass wir alle
heutzutage mehr oder weniger bereits
echtes iboxx sind demnach sind wir alle
unfassbar eng verbunden mit technischen
geräten smartphones das internet und
andere kommunikationsmöglichkeiten
halten wissen für uns bereit dass wir
niemals in unserem kopf speichern
könnten
und tatsächlich haben manche fitness
armbänder augmented reality oder smart
watch ist tatsächlich die funktion wie
implantate in früheren science fiction
film
ich hatte ja gerade schon erwähnt fest
steht nicht nur militär labore und
forschungsteams entwickeln neue
techniken in diesem bereich auch im
privaten bereich implantieren sich bio
hacker magnete oder funk chips mit denen
sie dann persönliche daten speichern
können oder eben ihre haustür öffnen
ganz ohne einen schlüssel und die
anhänger der trans humanistischen
vorstellung der evolution glauben an ein
eine extreme zukunft der menschen
demnach werden wir uns mit technischen
anwendungen auch abseits der
biologischen evolution weiterentwickeln
zukünftig wird es eine neue spezies
jenseits des biologischen menschen geben
die nicht mehr durch die psyche oder den
körper begrenzt ist dieser theorie nach
gibt es drei mögliche visionen zum einen
designer babys also ein genetisch neuer
mensch das sogenannte genom editing
macht es möglich die anhänger erhoffen
sich dass genmanipulation über
generationen menschen entstehen lassen
könnten die sich radikal von uns heute
unterscheiden die zweite version geht um
den implantierten neuen menschen 2 box
nano roboter im menschlichen körper
könnten die brüder aus mensch und
maschine widerstandsfähig machen
viele der menschlichen körperteile wären
demnach nicht mehr biologisch und die
dritte version der digitale mensch auch
upload genannt diese vision ist ziemlich
radikal der demnach wird das bewusstsein
des menschen durch eine vollständige
digitalisierung transformiert der name
dieses prozesses wholetrain emulation
oder auch ab loading das gehirn wird
hier also quasi als austauschbare
hardware definiert eine digitale
unsterblichkeit eingeschlossen
denn schließlich kann man von diesem so
geschaffenen neuen menschen beliebig
viel backups machen wo klar ist
jedenfalls die optimierung oder
erweiterung von menschen kann durch
verschiedene forschungsbereiche
geschehen und tatsächlich tüfteln teams
aus der medizin robotik und informatik
genauso wie aus dem bereich ki also
künstliche intelligenz an neue chancen
umgekehrt dagegen sind noch viele fragen
damit sichergestellt werden kann dass
die menschenwürde nicht verletzt wird
schwierig würde es auch wenn
manipulierte und instrumentalisierte
körper oder auch geist zu einer
unhinterfragt normwert moralische und
ethische diskussionen sind also genauso
wie rechtliche rahmenbedingungen
unabdingbar
ja wenn ihr als erstes neues zum thema
human enhancement und k erfahren wollt
dann endet meine telefonnummer hierbei
whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr vor allen an
von neuen videos also bevor sie online
gehen garantiert und zur begrüßung gibt
es ein kleines goodie einfach hier
draufklicken und nicht das aber
natürlich mit der genau glocke vergessen
hier geht es weiter dafür auch
draufklicken unvorstellbar kopf soll auf
9 körper transportiert werden auch in
absolutes thema also ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran